I guess there's only one way
let's run here to its raping time yeah
okay hey I knew that was gonna happen
can I have the keys please okay I don't
need the case it's kind of loose care oh
stop stop stop no now stop doing that oh
[ __ ] spider
please those smells dancer five is that
oh good [ __ ] man
ah here we go what is this crawl space
it's too dark
oh that's for the light a comb chain oh
god I don't like this
Oh like this
this is share what are you doing over
there get back in here
Oh Oh mr. chairman mr. sheriff we're in
big trouble mister share we're in big
[ __ ] trouble mr. chair let's get the
heck out of here message Adam chair mode
activate OOP I don't leave it like this
oh all right Oh another lantern hmm no
look I can open hey got Adam back
oh there's nothing that Thanks what it
what's going on anyway I just came from
that it's impossible why am I talking
like stephane all corridors I don't like
or dark this mission II put again
Oh even cannibal I love it
dumping it I dress oh well voila oh all
right it's okay go up like job this
[ __ ] head off
that's what you get Bo III didn't mean
to do it I swear he read for me and I
just clicked I didn't want to chop his
that out I just pray that goes oh I'm
fine
are you stomach bugs in with you mouse
did you put the box there you [ __ ]
barrel okay
ah [ __ ] wish oh I'm a leg twisted my
leg
how do we get it down I'm gonna go back
there but now for damn dad
bells don't you dare [ __ ] tell me
where I am here ma'am I swear to God I
[ __ ] kill you put your [ __ ] chair
ah yeah Mamadou shook fair
it's safe pay that you can go how's it
going bros my name is pierre hope you
enjoyed this video if you did why not
like it or attitude favorites why not
bomb
I don't even subscribe to become a bro
today and if you're already a bro you
could always use this new feature on
YouTube I don't even know anymore
the quick show subscriptions and enemy
and it should be easier to find my video
just a broad tip also leave a comment
telling me whatever you want and that's
pretty much it